all right as the world once again
focused today on former president Donald
Trump's every movement uh every second
every minute every hour every day our
colleagues at Fox News digital they did
a very deep dive on Biden's travels on
Air Force two as vice president and
their analysis found that Hunter oh
Hunter Biden visited at least 13
different countries while tagging along
with dear old dad and wouldn't you know
it many of those trips were places where
Hunter was trying to do business that
includes China and Mexico and Serbia
China and Mexico they did business
Hunter even had Secret Service
protection with him at beautiful Lake
Como haven't been there yet in Italy in
2014 when he was offered a spot on
barista's board and by the way where is
Hunter now on vacation with Daddy at
Lake Tahoe where the first family is
apparently too busy working out to pay
attention to anything even going on in
the world take a look
I've been working out for the last hour
working out
the guy can't even pull his beach chair
um anyway here with reaction Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy Senator great to
have you
so you see what's going on in the
country Senator
um the advice to see ears to hear you
watch what's going on if you have any
knowledge at all if you're not watching
the mainstream media mob uh obsessively
compulsively talk about Trump every
second of every day we've learned a lot
about Joe Biden and his son Hunter and
their foreign business dealings and
first he said he never talked to his son
brother or anybody now we know that he
was actively making phone calls that he
was meeting with oligarchs at some Cafe
Milano sounds like a pretty ritzy place
to me
and that Hunter was getting tens of
millions of dollars in the field of
energy and other other fields in which
he had no experience at a time when he
admits he was addicted to drugs and he
admits and his emails confirming that uh
Hunter was paying dad's bills for his
home repairs giving half his income to
Pops and Pops were getting 10 as the big
guy why do you think think we have how
do you analyze this for the people at
home that are trying to make sense of
this because it sounds to me like
America's justice system is turned on
its head we've got one for republicans
and one for Democrats
well it seems to me Sean that uh
Hunter gate is about two things
privilege
and sleaze first the privilege President
Biden and many members of the media
lecture us incessantly
about the injustice
of privilege especially so-called white
privilege
but to me that's like being lectured
about gun safety by Alec Baldwin
because when they when they lecture us
about privilege they never mention
Hunter Biden who is the epitome of
privilege
how did honor Biden earn these millions
of dollars is it because he's so smart
how smart is it to turn over a laptop
with incriminating information to a
stranger
how smart is it to try to deduct your
hookers on your federal income tax
um did the uh the Ukrainian and Chinese
companies pick Mr Hunter Biden because
they were impressed with his resume on
ZipRecruiter
no
it was his daddy
it was always about his daddy Hunter
Biden is just a vessel
um he's just a lucky sperm
and and the next time that you are
lectured we are lectured about about
privilege I want people to remember that
point two
if you are fair-minded
and have any sort of moral compass
all this sleaze surrounding Hunter Biden
and President Biden and their family has
got to make you want to gag
now I know what the official White House
line is the official White House line is
that look President Biden is just a a a
good family man
who talks to um six out of his seven
grandchildren every day
and who is such a swelled daddy that he
regularly calls into Hunter's business
meetings to talk about weather
now if you believe that you will never
own your own home
at a minimum
at a minimum the evidence brought forth
by the house and by Senator Grassley by
the way in the Senate is Clarion clear
that President Biden was well aware of
what his son was doing
and he aggressively enabled it
and that's Sleazy and he also got
enriched what does this mean for our
country senator
um
to me it means it can mean one of two
things
it can mean Justice
if the house is allowed to just get the
truth
I I want the truth I'm not accusing
anybody of a crime it'll it'll be up to
the courts to decide if someone did
something illegal but in no Universe in
no universe uh is this is this right I
don't care how you pretty it up if the
house is allowed to get the facts and
show them to the American people I think
it it can be good for our country but if
the justice department just says oh we
can't talk about it uh we're
investigating they've been investigating
five years and it's beginning to look
more and more like Mr Weiss uh the U.S
attorney is severely compromised I
couldn't believe that attorney general
Garland actually made him a special
counsel
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy thank you
as always hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else